well if you can't believe it there are
people in this world who don't like me i
know i'm as surprised as you are and
some of those people are on tick tock so
today we thought it'd be fun and really
good for my self-esteem to take a dive
down the rabbit hole of anti-matte walls
tik tok videos just to see you know what
all these people think and why they hate
me so much and maybe they'll be able to
make good arguments and i'll listen to
the argument and at the end i'll say you
know what they're right i hate myself
too i am a i am a bastard um so we'll
find out we'll start
um we'll just we'll just kind of go
random here and uh let's start with this
one all right a lot of politics this
week it's been pretty weird man let's
take a look at a little bit of dating
advice from the right
the modern dating scene is what happens
when every beggar becomes a chooser
everyone is lonely and desperate for
companionship but the field is so
flooded with options there's such a
surplus that you begin to feel like kind
of like i feel when i'm
in the condiment aisle at walmart trying
to buy mustard i wish i could say that
him comparing women to mustard was the
weirdest part of this video but it's
totally not
97 different types of mustard and though
all i want is just regular mustard the
overwhelming array of options paralyzes
me and i'm just standing there slack jaw
and questioning whether i should be
settling for just regular muscle does
this dude have a mustard fetish or it's
just that you can't settle on any one
thing because your awareness that there
are billions of other possibilities
gives you anxiety um i can guarantee you
right now that this guy never had a lot
of options instead of a boundless
never-ending buffet of options a young
person in a culture that practices
arranged marriages will be assigned just
one and they don't even make the choice
this dude is definitely in a loveless
marriage
their families just pair them up and say
here you go
bruh no
there's far less freedom and far less
autonomy in a system of that sort but it
is without a doubt
superior to our system so i'm pretty
sure he's saying that he's unhappy with
his wife because she's basically like
generic mustard
and that he would have been better off
if his family could have made a
transaction and he could have got the
cream of the crop
so a couple things here i mean one of
his arguments against me is and i quote
bruh no bruh
put some damn effort into it like this
guy i don't know you know he's got a
very small tick tock following he's
trying to become i guess everybody on
tick tock wants to be a social media
influencer put some freaking effort into
it at least like come up with better
insults you you have time to think about
this it's not like no one ran up to you
on the street and put a camera in your
face and said respond to this clip of
matt walsh you had time to think about
what your insults are going to be put
some effort into it the best you could
come up with is bruh no i put more
effort into it than you do and that's
the most insulting thing if anyone
should be being lazy here it should be
me second
there's a i have a requirement
i'm making a new rule and it's that if
you're going to respond to a man's
argument in this way because the other
thing he says besides bruh no which is a
compelling argument the other thing he
says is that i'm in a loveless marriage
and you know implying that my wife is
ugly and whatever so if you're gonna do
that you have to show your receipts okay
first tell us whether you're married and
show us who you're married to see the
thing is
all this this dork in this hoodie can do
to respond to my argument besides saying
bruh no is make faces at the camera and
imply that my wife is ugly and that i
didn't have options or whatever
but
rather than going that route
you could
not
put all that to the side and then and
you could free your brain
to actually think about these concepts
and come up with an actually interesting
response
freeze your mind free
your mind
if you have one at all to be freed you
know as the uh as somebody with four
kids in the house and plus a dog so i
don't know who in the end makes more of
a mess but they all do uh that's why
sometimes you gotta you gotta take uh
cleaning very seriously in the home at
least my wife does when it comes to
cleaning your home you want a cleaning
product that not only is effective but
also is safe that's why i recommend
naturally it's clean a home cleaning
company dedicated to providing the most
effective cleaning products for your
home while reducing the use of harmful
chemicals their secret well it's
powerful plant-based enzymes nature's
solution to cleaning and when i say
powerful i'm talking about
hospital-grade enzyme cleaning power
they have solutions for almost every
need in the house from the kitchen to
the bathroom to the laundry room
naturally it's clean has a specialized
formula to clean the area effectively
their products truly speak for
themselves and they have the science to
back up that's why i'm encouraging my
listeners to start with four of their
top products conveniently packaged
together in the daily wire essentials
kit and for a limited time my listeners
can receive 15 off their order enter
promo code matt at checkout when you
visit naturaleatsclean.com
matt try these incredible products in
your home today shipping is free and
everything is made right here in the usa
again try our naturally it's clean daily
wire 4 pack today by going to
naturallyitsclean.com and use promo code
matt to receive 15 off your purchase
don't delay make the smarter safer
choice for your home cleaning needs
today with naturally it's clean um okay
let's move on i made the mistake of
hopping on facebook real quick
and saw
a really nasty comment
that i'm going to read you guys
so the initial post was against woke
culture and the media and this person
got on and commented with a matt walsh
quote if that doesn't set the tone for
you right there i'm going to read this
part of it to you real quick amazon has
that new lord of the rings prequel
trilogy coming out they spent like a
billion dollars on it a lot of people
including many conservatives are very
excited about it because they're big
lord of the rings fans well don't you
understand this is amazon what do you
think they're going to do to it and then
you're going to sit down and watch it
and be disappointed because there's a
trans non-binary disabled hobbit or
something if you're trans non-binary or
disabled
i'm so sorry
anyone say something like this
evangelical christians are represented
all over the place you're still like the
majority in our government
you're in all the media and the movies
and the tv shows
you don't have a clue what it
feels like and then you sit and whine
and and moan that you're being
persecuted oh boo hoo are you scared of
people
realizing that those of us who are
different than you are actually way more
kind and fun
and pretty badass and that people might
actually like us more
than you
and why do you hate woke culture so much
because you don't want to know a society
full of people that care
that love people that show compassion
that fight for social justice like oh
that sounds terrible because who wants
to live in a society where people
actually act like jesus okay and how do
we start a petition to actually get a
trans non-binary disabled habit in the
next lord of the rings because that
would be pretty sweet okay uh well that
was good i love that and i love the
message it's an interesting message
which is f you were way more kind than
you are so you know we're way nicer and
more respectful and tolerant than you
damned worthless pieces of garbage um
that's a great message not contradictory
at all either it's never easy being the
bigger person though i was disappointed
that she apologized on my behalf to
trans non-binary and disabled people but
did not apologize to hobbits because to
be clear that's specifically who i was
attacking in my statement are trans
non-binary
disabled hobbits can't stand them you
know and i don't mean to upset this
person even more but i also i'm also
bigoted against polyamorous elves and
lesbian wizards there are a lot of those
i don't like gender queer orcs
though there are a lot of those on tick
tock i've seen
anyway i'm bigoted against all kinds of
fictional characters but you know the
greatest thing is that she starts the
video by being offended by my premise
and then ends it by agreeing with the
premise because she's mad that i said
that there would be a non-binary
disabled trans hobbit and at the end she
says yeah you know what i would actually
like that i want one of those
so i know you do
you weirdo that's the point the point is
that you want entertainment that does
nothing but affirm your worldview
because your worldview is so fragile and
and you yourself are so fragile and and
in need of so much affirmation all the
time and so that all entertainment has
to be focused primarily on that which
means that it's not entertaining anymore
it's not it's not like telling a story
everything is just in service to you and
your ego that's the issue with it that's
why we don't want it okay and to top it
all off
she repeatedly misgendered me as an
evangelical which i am not i'm a
catholic okay we're not all the same you
bigot
um let's see what else do we got even as
a dancer she isn't doing anything that
other young pop divas can't do
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
okay they're not saying their best
they're not saying their best you're
just proving my point i all you're
literally just showing me her videos of
of her shaking her ass
to the camera like
that that's my right that's that's my
point like any any pop star can do that
that's what they've all been doing
forever so is beyonce
a better than average
ass shaker
probably so i mean i'll give her that um
she's she's above average
on the pop star scale let's be honest
they're all pretty good at it that's how
they got to the point where they are but
she so if the average pop star would in
terms of ash shaking is a b plus she's
an a minus maybe even an a plus i'll
give you that but that's but that's it
it's just like degrees of ash shaking is
is all that beyonce really brings to the
table now you also showed in the video
you showed taylor swift now i'm not one
to try to defend taylor swift at all but
i will say and i'm sure that beyonce is
a better dancer than her but taylor
swift is an example of someone as a pop
star who does something that beyonce
can't do which is write her own music i
don't know if taylor swift still does
that i don't really follow her that well
but i know at some point at least she
was actually writing her own music and
she'll play an instrument so she'll play
an instrument
now is the music good no it's torturous
okay
but she can write it and play it beyonce
can't do any of that she doesn't write
her own music she can't play an
instrument
she can dance and like the singing is
it's okay i mean the singing is like a c
plus on the pop star scale
ass shaking is an a plus averages are
out to about a b
but there's a whole lot of things
musically that she can't do
such as
literally everything
except shaker has i think we can end on
that note that is i'm sure we'll have
wide agreement and uh not be
controversial at all you know after all
this i i've listened to everybody's
arguments about why they hate me and uh
i have i've heard them out and i'm just
i'm not i don't i i'm not fully
convinced i i have not been convinced to
hate myself i mean i do kind of hate
myself but it's got nothing to do with
these videos so i guess that's the point
don't you sometimes hate yourself
constantly well those are all the people
that uh hate me and there are a few
others out there but uh look if you're
in the sweet baby gang and you want to
show these people
the truth or if you want to be the sweet
baby gang either way uh then make sure
that you come back to the channel and
that you hit subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell and do
it now